though I still love you guys though man
you guys is the [ __ ] you guys also
molded my life a lot oh definit bro boys
to men man you know when I first got
dumped I think that's that's how I
started memorizing all these bright back
really
because Brian McKnight and boys - man
yeah all for one all these guys started
be going to my rolodex for my heartache
yeah yeah yeah like but it helped Oh a
hundred percent right yo the first time
I ever got dumped I remember I hit up my
best friend and then he took me in his
Honda Accord his burgundy Honda Accord
busted ass [ __ ] lemon yeah we went to
a wendy's went into the Wendy's parking
lot got ourselves a double bacon
cheeseburger some chili and some fries
and when I took that first bite I
started crying this was a bro was
probably she left me that cheeseburger
oh my god dude I cried in a parking lot
eating a [ __ ] bacon double
cheeseburger my gosh when I first got
dumped listening to bright midnight
music oh man yo let me ask you this
have you ever imagined like whenever you
had like a breakup or like a big fight
that you know your you had like the
drama moment right you're sitting there
and you just imagine them like running
in and say I'm sorry it sure like that I
sometimes I look at Muriel and I want
her to leave me so I could make dope
music I'm Perl dude like I want to look
at Mary oh say hey I just want to come
up to a bill hey [ __ ] yeah get the [ __ ]
out and then I go to you and your guilt
let's write this crap dude she broke my
[ __ ] heart
yo but honestly though like sometimes
you need I mean it's terrible but like
some dude in July external stimuli like
that like whether it be for music or
anything else like something that really
even for fitness yeah sometimes like you
know it could motivate you to really
just or push you over the edge of being
like indecisive of what you yeah man I
feel music to like if you're not
emotionally connected or yeah as an
artist if you're not emotionally
connected there's no way that you could
really tap into this area right and I I
you know I've been getting a lot of like
messages from people I haven't talked to
in a very long time yeah and you know
that whole crazy rich Asians things
happen yeah and I want to be an actor I
feel like I could do it yeah listen here
you emotionless [ __ ] like you can't do
[ __ ] not because like well you know it
is you don't have the gift or the talent
yeah
and you also and even beyond that you
don't have to work ethic for it
right and that's what it is you're hyped
up because you see somebody else do
something that you want to catch that
way well guess what there's been a lot
of people on that way they just haven't
had the voice for yeah and so what makes
you think that you're gonna be the next
thing dude like I talked about this [ __ ]
man there was this guy that uh comes up
to me messages me and he goes yo man I
saw crazy rich Asians and he was like yo
I want to be the next biggest action
star I was like first of all the [ __ ]
does that mean
yeah alright and I was like okay so what
are you doing to become you know yeah he
goes well I started taking a kickboxing
class okay hold on second yeah go take a
[ __ ] acting class [ __ ] loser right
you know like he he like okay so you are
that missing piece mm-hmm that nobody
has heard about he goes well I feel like
there aren't any Asian American actors
that's doing you know what I'm doing in
the that can do in the action scene and
I'm like what do you mean Jet Li yeah
you mean Jackie Chan yeah life you've
never heard of those people before leave
it's a badlands could Daniel woo what's
his name the Badlands guy oh yes I mean
this is all these [ __ ] you [ __ ]
little Fiat boy isn't that what we're
known for it exactly like the so he
takes a kickboxing class you know and I
gave it to him like what I'm telling you
right now and I'm be open about saying
this cuz I told him is to his [ __ ]
fear yeah you know and I I tell this
story right now I'm not gonna tell his
name out because that's kind of [ __ ]
up but other than that and I hope you're
listening to this again you little
[ __ ] [ __ ] I love you but yeah you
know that it's such a [ __ ] up concept
because I think it's disrespect for
those people who have been doing it
right for years and you don't think that
they're trying to get those roles right
right that you think that you're gonna
walk in and take it from them ya know
you're not gonna do it right it's gonna
take work yeah if you understand the
work that goes behind yeah yeah be my
guest coming to this Roman let's have
that serious conversation right and I
think that that's that's the weird
conversation I always have to have and
they think I had this key to unlock it
for them yeah well I mean I think
there's nothing wrong with wanting that
right yeah but you just have to be
prepared and you know realize that it's
it's it's more than meets the eye yeah
you know what I mean sometimes I don't
think people well I don't think they
spend enough time to really think about
how much it actually will
yeah people don't like I even put it
like this